hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting
to kevin samuel savage moments
it's tough in the comment section i get
like two complaints one
don't just piggyback off of other
people's content
i'm like guys this is a reaction channel
i don't know what you want from me hold
on and
second thing is that
more kevin samuels more kevin samuels
so i will give the people what they want
i'll probably make some original content
at some point but i really just made
this as like
a reaction account
all right let's go someone called in the
other day and i said ma'am
at your height and your weight i mean no
offense man
but you're the size of a middle
linebacker i don't understand that type
of question
well here's here's the thing men don't
do what you just did
because there's always a low-level
threat of violence between men when
lines are crossed
when i as the host of a show
start speaking and you continue to talk
as if
i'm not saying a word that is
disrespectful you would not do that
anywhere you would do it at work at
church in a restaurant
but you will have no problem
disrespecting a black man
[ __ ] what i'm saying i'm going to keep
on saying what i got to say
this this i don't care what this dude is
saying you're disrespectful
damn you're doing a little too much
right now okay
i'm trying to be polite but now i'm
about to go there
don't overtalk me when i'm trying to
speak you need to listen and all i'm
trying to understand is are you a part
of these
pretty professional women are you going
to talk about paper girls
so paper women i i consider myself more
[ __ ] over talking didn't you just ask
her a question
but yeah no she she does not seem like
professional i've said it before all
right
what would you are you would you
consider yourself to be a professional
i consider myself to be a free spirit
all right
a free spiritual job i'm gonna free you
i don't know why half these girls never
answered questions
another roman rome i don't need to do
all that i'm gonna be a phlebotomist you
see
then i'm gonna get in and work the
insurance path
and then i'm gonna have my dream to
where it can make me a six figure dude
while i'm drawing blood and dispensing
jello
but that's how we do it around here man
if you don't shut up
a big dick i mean it's above average i
ain't no ron jeremy
no no no no no i asked you if you had a
big dick i just said it wasn't above
average
i don't know what that is really uh
[ __ ] you know if you got a big dick or
not stop the [ __ ]
oh no never do you know what not he got
a big dick i know i've never heard him
come after me oh i got a big
yes really what's the problem
oh you can check that [ __ ] that don't
fly here sis
i'm saying you asked me my name and i
told it well i'll tell you i'll tell you
right now here's what you do
you either get that attitude and check
or get off my phone
i didn't have attitude yes you did i'm
gonna tell you right now
you either get it in check or get off my
phone i just said really i'm happy
all right chick i'm not gonna do this
with you goodbye
otasia your mama shoulda did that to you
that's incorrect and the reason why i
say that is because you know i
um i have and i'm not talking about
a one-off i am around a lot of high
earning men
all the time and but but i will say that
these are white man
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding are you
black
are you black okay so
tell me the tell me the high earning
black men that you are around who are
americans
he went to jail oh so you pick
ass whoopers and felons and then you're
gonna complain about what other
i need you to stop right here ma'am i
need you to slow down
i need you i need you to slow the whole
french toast down
i'm not gonna let you get on here and
talk about what black men are not when
you picking
dudes to whoop your ass and they're the
felons
i've talked about this you can't say men
are trash if the men you
choose to date you choose today are
trash
i say this all the time i hate when
girls say that
but i felt it at one point like i've
been there but
you gotta realize ladies if you choose
to date trash man that's your own fault
see i'm not gonna sit around and let you
black women just sit around talk about
black men ain't here and ain't this they
ain't dead when in your own life
you pick [ __ ] especially an
[ __ ] with socially awkward who thinks
he's funny
that means [ __ ] may work on with you
with your action figures and your comic
books but it doesn't work in the world
and it usually isn't mr samuels
well let me ask you so you know
so you get people like vip and free
drinks
yes okay
um see what we just did this is why
i don't know no
hell no
i'm saying i'm trying to understand
what's the what's the philosophy here
you're not a virgin you got two people
came out of you what
what's going on oh no you did not oh no
you did not have the nerve to bring
vagina out here and close it up at 37
years old with two kids
out here and i'ma tell you the reason
behind that is because when i do
open my legs they the men beg they get
crazy
do you damn have women issues
because it seems like you do
that's not a question that's a judge do
you
have women issues that is the question
do you have
do i have women issues yeah because
they're sorry listen
we're gonna do this i was i'm being
polite i'm trying to let you speak
but you got a point
you got a point so you asked me did i
have a question that was my question
yeah do i have women issues no
you don't no no this mother sucker
didn't
check that attitude
i'm 23 you're 23 i'm 51 obviously me
i'm not your peer young lady what do you
ladies get off talking to a grown damn
man
like i'm a kid
no matter how i try to talk to you no
matter how i try to see it
it's the same thing understand this and
understand this well
if you go out and make a baby outside
the bonds of marriage
you are cutting off your opportunity for
high value men the next one
this one is gonna hurt okay i just read
a comment the other day that said
if a woman's divorced that's like better
than
like if a woman has kids
and has been divorced versus was never
married
it's better for finding like a husband
next time around
let me know in the comments if someone
could explain like why
i need you ladies to go ahead and get
get your glass get your riesling
or your pinot noir or your zinfandel or
whatever i need to go ahead and take a
a take a good good three get a good
mouthful don't just sip take a big goat
okay if you don't drink wine fine
get your scoop get your haagen-dazs and
put the teaspoon down and go ahead and
get you the whole tablespoon don't even
get the tablespoon
go get that big wooden spoon and get you
a big wooden spoon
of ice cream and go ahead and chug that
down your pie hole
okay i think your standards are a little
off
i hate okay i hate when women
tell men who they should date look
i'm pale it's gonna benefit me in the
wrong
long run because i'm not gonna get skin
cancer and i'll probably have less
wrinkles than someone who tanned all the
time
but i'm not gonna be mad if guys don't
like tall
pale gingers can't you know
you know how many times i've been like
looked over for a 5 5 brunette
i can't help that like i'm but i'm not
mad
just like they can't be mad if i like a
tall guy
like or if i have a preference for like
dating like my boyfriend's like
6'3 so
like like i would probably pass a
five-five guy
like bish who are you talking to
i mean seriously i mean seriously it
ain't no no see now you've gone to the
now you now you've gone there
i'm a professional image consultant who
the who are you
you're just a woman who think you're all
that and you're not my standards are
right where they need to be
and you can either accept what it is go
look at your go look at your calendar
see how many prince and and kings and
earls and dukes are trying to take you
out to dinner to regular reservations
because that's what a shone up eight or
nine would have
you see what that just happened in the
chat room i had a girl
okay are you are you currently sexually
active or you have you ever been
sexually active
excuse me you're using
are you a virgin i ask these questions
to everybody else before you
yes but you no no no no no i asked these
questions to everyone else before you
please answer the question are you a
virgin yes or no
sure all right uh you can either
answer the question or i can just you
can leave
yes you're a virgin all right
said a guy he almost hit a weird boy
maybe a parakeet some goldfish
a couple of honda civics y'all go to
rainy tuesdays
and you know outback i mean this is this
is your life
oh my god i mean so hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on and this is why i
need you
i know i'm you sound like i'm joking but
i need to understand i'm i'm talking
about a man
who's a solid decent man
i'm not talking about a bomb i'm talking
about an average working man
who works hard for his [ __ ] money
a solid tax paying god friend mother
loving apple pie hot dog baseball
[ __ ] citizen
and you're chuckling like i'm joking i
don't play when i'm talking about the
men i respect and advocate for
and you ladies think just because you're
making a little bit more money
you can laugh at these men that's some
[ __ ]
i agree like the women that's like
laughs
we'll laugh at guys they make 85k
or 75 that's
that's not bad money it's probably above
average
especially when you're average
and you were below average and get off
my no
in la is 20 000 in atlanta
ten dollars an hour you are
broke and i'm when ryan pressing
who said she feels that the min that she
is bringing
more to the table of getting a raw deal
ma'am
you will be fortunate to have somebody
who would be willing to even go
50 50 with you for the rest of your life
at your age and your your
attitudinal disposition you need a
reality check and let me be the one to
give it to you
you don't bring that much to the table
as a woman who
lives herself a six in la
as a waitress you're
massively over valuing yourself you made
me give myself a six
years no no i asked you what you i no
ma'am you ain't that fine
and that's the thing sir that's not fair
it is fair
it is fair well you can put your camera
on right now put it on get on the camera
right now then
let's shut cam up she won't
cameron ain't that fair cam the [ __ ] up
that's nice
cam the [ __ ] up shut up and cam up your
grown child
listen what she just said it's not a 40
year old child
oh my gosh she's 40.
stop you don't have nobody's forcing
these women to call into his show
that's what confuses me is these women
all ask for his advice
and they don't take it like i totally
get disagreeing with him on some stuff
but like
don't don't call into his show but let
me know in the comments um if you agree
or disagree and what video i should do
next
thank you guys